chestnut
once unrated yeah i think i have a lot
of challenges right now so apologies to
all the people who
wasn't able to accept but we still got
plenty of time
and uh if it were up to me i'd play
every single one
knight f5 thank you very much
what's chesney doing
think for a moment i thought
a chestnut is just playing fast so i
think
see he's ahead in the clock for 10 11
seconds
so chestnut's idea is just to flag me
clearly
yeah i like this guy he just plays fast
fast and furious bishop d6
yeah i like this guy just play fast and
now he's way ahead on the clock
flag the opponent
yeah it could very well work against
others
yes he is way ahead on the clock now he
pushes his pawns
let's give him a chance let's sacrifice
our rook
and see what happens now the game is
very complicated
but i have a lot of pawns on the king
side
i have four connected pawns that's a lot
of pawns
then i play bishop d4
[Laughter]
oh chestnut you almost had me
okay i have to take this rook
i already played him